howdy howdy howdy welcome back to New
rockstars I'm Anna vanston and welcome
to the first video of a brand new series
10 fun facts you can think of it as like
a miniature breakdown just a little
condensed supplement of a breakdown that
you can wash down with a cold glass of
knowledge which is also this video I
lost the metaphor anyway today we're
going to be covering a gem of filmmaking
history the first feature-length CGI
movie to ever be made
there are hundreds of fun facts about
this movie but here are 10 particularly
fun ones am I team odd but I want to
start in Sid's room because this thing
is packed to the gills with little
Easter eggs that are easy to miss like
Sid has a Binford toolbox which was the
fictional brand from Home Improvement
AKA The Amazing 90s show that starred
Tim Allen AKA Buzz Lightyear and that
reference is just mwah AKA good his
walls are lined with parody posters like
this web of Terror poster that's
parodying old posters of the movie The
Fly this megadork poster parroting the
band mega death and also this guy has a
Mickey Mouse tattoo on his arm and two
posters which actually show up in other
movies a copy of his poster killing Paul
Bunyan and his blue ox of Doom which is
such a metal title can also be seen in
Monsters Inc when one of the monsters
runs out of a door saying that a kid
almost touched him and The Wraith rock
monster poster is in the background of
this guy's mind space and inside out now
Sid also has a poster that seems to be
inspired by artist Rat Fink however I
also found an artist named Joseph
Alexander rape yes like there a wraith
poster right next to the poster in
question and when you look at his
portfolio he's done some incredibly
similar art to the movies poster and had
also created a tribute to rat fink
before and then I saw that one of his
clients had been Disney the name on the
neighboring poster the artwork the
client history could this be the person
who drew the artwork for the poster so I
emailed him to ask and he was kind
enough to get back to me and the answer
is no it's just a wild coincidence but
my job is to provide you the facts now
you have them either way wraith's
artwork is fantastic but it seems like
this poser is probably a rat big tribute
some other fun details are the fireworks
brand that Sid buys ill eagle and when
Babyface Taps out Morse code their
spelling RR come out RR standing for
received or Roger Roger how much toys no
Morse code well a hint might be in
Andy's room where a Buzz Lightyear
poster teaches deep space code which is
just Morse code there are also little
employee nods everywhere cat mole root
beer was named after Pixar's at the time
president and co-founder Ed catmull
Eggman and Eggman movers was art
director Ralph eggleston's login name
and Sid's backpack says Julie mcbarfield
has cooties as a result of editorial and
Camera manager Julie M McDonald loving
to get her name put in the film heading
to the living room of Sid's house a
personal favorite fact of mine is that
the yelling voice in The Buzz Lightyear
commercial is none other than Penn
Gillette teller was probably also there
too you just couldn't hear him to
replicate the aggressive nature of
commercials in those days the team
pondered who had the most assaultive
voice they could think of and the answer
was pendulate
reportedly he was so loud in the
recording studio that they could hear
him in the lobby through the soundproof
walls and in addition Eggleston director
and co-writer John Lasseter and
screenwriter and storyboard artist
Andrew Stanton were the ones that said
Buzz Lightyear in the commercial
you probably caught a few references in
this movie but you might be surprised to
find out just how many classic movies
and shows the Toy Story team Drew from
there are movie references everywhere
and in the movie's commentary track they
talked about a bunch of references that
made it into the movie the army man
getting stepped on and saying go on
without me and start saying a good
soldier never leaves a man behind was a
call back to the Trope that appeared in
many a classic Army film in Buzz's POV
when we first meet him you can hear
breathing much like Vader's in Star Wars
the sequence where Buzz is having to
escape perils is inspired by Indiana
Jones Raiders of the Lost Ark even down
to the spielbergian camera movements and
sound effects the sound the push pins
make Echo the arrows from the movie
and the sound of the ball he's running
from is the same as the rolling Boulder
end of the sequence you can hear the
famous Wilhelm screen
and Rex saying what is a boy to a
panicked RC is in fact a lassie
reference moving outside of Andy's house
they said that Woody and Buzz's fight at
the gas station took inspiration from
classic Arnold Schwarzenegger fight
scenes and Buzz does a Vulcan salute
from Star Trek when walking off when
they get to Pizza Planet the lights in
the eyes of the centuries at the
entrance move back and forth like the
cylons in Battlestar Galactica inside we
get an alien reference with the game
Waka alien and the green aliens all
pointing up to the claw and wanting to
surround and touch Buzz are references
to Close Encounters of the Third Kind
heading over to Sid's house sits
interrogation of Woody had elements of a
mix of Star Wars and the interrogation
from Raiders of the Lost Ark and if you
thought the carpet in the hallway looked
familiar you might have recognized it
from The Shining in that same hallway
during the scene where scud the dog
wakes up his eye dilation and growling
was meant to mimic that of the T-Rex in
Jurassic Park finally continuing their
somewhat strange shorts at anger
Fascination the scene where woody slaps
Buzz with his own arm was taken from a
story the team had heard about
Schwarzenegger asking the director on
the set of Commando if he could do a
take where after cutting off a guy's
Army hits him with his own fist which
the director was like I think that might
be going too far so the Toy Story team
heard then were like we'll do it
resulting in the iconic Mrs Nesbitt
moment but one of my all-time favorite
Parts is when Woody is looking for his
hat and the shark pops up I'm Woody
howdy howdy howdy
give me that which I had no idea at the
time was quoting a Far Side comic with a
very similar line another fantastic
moment is when Woody opens Buzz's helmet
and just stands there while he quote
unquote suffocates cult but Woody's
reaction was actually a blessed accident
animator Doug Sweetland was doing a
rough pass on the scene and ran out of
time before he could get to Woody's
reaction so when the clip showed during
the dailies Woody just turned his head
the team fell on the floor laughing and
told him to please keep it that way we
made this video with the help of geology
and with their help you can make your
skin healthier than ever geology is a 22
time award winning skin hair and body
care company recognized in men's health
Oprah daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and
GQ their products are built around just
a handful of powerful proven ingredients
that have entrusted by dermatologists
for decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz in geology will create a
simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
geology's co-wash and deodorant are
great and I use them all the time but
right now they're running a special
offer for a skin care sampler pack and
glg's Skin Care stuff is in a league of
its own geology's line of skin care
products can help you fight acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging there has
never been a better time to try geology
than right now for a very limited time
use code rockstars 100 to get 100 off
more personalized 30-day skincare sample
set all you have to do is cover the 495
for shipping on top of that new Rockstar
fans get an exclusive bonus offer up to
50 off on an additional skin hair hair
or body product of your choice when you
add it to your trial click the link in
the description or go to
g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e slash rockstars100
to get started believe it or not not
everyone wanted a slice of the Toy Story
pie back in the day which is hard to
imagine since it's become such a mega
success but for instance Woody's love
interest was originally supposed to be
Barbie but they couldn't get the rights
from Mattel in the first script when the
toys are trying to escape Sid's room one
of the toys was going to go through the
vent to go to Hannah's room and get help
and then screeching through the door
would be Barbie and her pink Corvette in
a prom dress the team said she would
have been tough as nails like Linda
Hamilton from Terminator 2 she would
have grabbed a Woody and said come with
me if you want to live before going
through an epic chase scene where scud
raced after the car Woody also had a
line written in about wishing he was
anatomically correct in that scene
regardless Mattel wouldn't lend the
rights wanting to avoid defining
Barbie's personality and instead opting
for children to project their own
imagined personality traits onto her
they clearly had a change of heart for
the second one though and the Toy Story
team he said bet but they also worked a
joke in the first one where Rex says
he's from Mattel and then says well I'm
not really from Mattel I'm actually from
a much smaller company that was
purchased in a leveraged buyout Mattel
wasn't the only one though Hasbro turned
down the rights to GI Joe when they
found out that Sid was going to be
blowing one up which led to the creation
and doomed fate of the fictional combat
Carl they nailed the accuracy of the
toys they could get though right down to
their movements they did have to get
imaginative for some of them though in
order to figure out how the green army
men would move the animation team nailed
an old pair of sneakers to a plank of
wood and hauled it across the room
creating what we see on screen one great
toy that I feel doesn't get enough love
is Mr spell and part of that under
appreciation comes from so many of its
jokes happening in the background he
laughs when Mr Potato Heads making fun
of Slinky he stutters on his you're
welcome scream for a frame when everyone
is panicking he's counting the calories
buzzes burning on the treadmill during a
montage and he's in the background
saying hubba hubba when it's announced
that Andy got a Mrs Potato Head there
was even going to be a scene at the end
where the toys were having a Christmas
Christmas party and Buzz was going to be
singing Let It Snow while using Mr spell
as a karaoke machine but it was cut
instead he says the non-denominational
have a merry and a happy that's really
all he says he gets cut off eventually
Jeff pigeon the voice of Mr spell also
provided his voice for the aliens along
with a few other voice actors and they
achieved that iconic Voice by inhaling
helium before saying the lines and I
have a moral obligation to say don't try
this at home kids many of the Toy Story
toys had a pretty cut and dry design
from the beginning since they were based
on pre-existing toys but our two main
Heroes went through quite a journey to
end up where they did I mean Woody
wasn't even the main character at First
the movie was going to center around
tinny a character from a previous Pixar
short called tin toy and Woody was going
to be the sidekick he meets and was
originally drafted as a regular wooden
ventriloquist dummy with a top hat once
it was decided that the plot would be
about a new toy coming in and replacing
an old toy as a child's favorite Denny
was scrapped as it wasn't believable
that an old tin toy like him would
become a child's new favorite plaything
enter Buzz at that point named lunar
Larry who was a little red astronaut toy
soon after character designer Bud lucky
made a suggestion that would he be made
a cowboy which provided the perfect
contrast to an astronaut so he became a
cowboy ventriloquist dummy problem was
to try to portray a more adult tone in
the movie they gave Woody the snarky
attitude but he ended up just being kind
of a d-bag and everyone hated him so
they lightened his attitude and
friendlied up his design a little bit
creating the Woody we all know and love
you can actually see a picture that
resembles an earlier version of Woody on
the wall in Andy's room so then lunar
Larry eventually evolved into Tempest
from morph a name that thankfully
changed to buzz after astronaut Buzz
Aldrin and was given a new Sleek white
design to make him stand out from the
rest of the colorful toys and make him
feel new and contemporary the team
combine all their favorite childhood
toys features to make the ultimate dream
toy so they made him the size of a GI
Joe gave him the karate chop action and
risk Communicator that the big Gym
series of toys had added voice commands
and LED lights based on the at the time
super modern video Command action figure
series which ran from 1991 to 1993 and
topped it all off with wings a
glow-in-the-dark effect and laser
pointer Stanton who owned big gym toys
as a kid also said that big Jim having
the words made in China under the lid of
his risk Communicator led to the team
putting made in Taiwan under buzzes as
well one last cheeky detail about Buzz
is that he's got a Disney logo on his
booty which changes to a Disney Pixar
logo in the third movie the toys aren't
the only ones we have to consider though
never wondered what the story with
Andy's dad is why he's not in the
picture well it's mostly because he's
too expensive humans especially at that
time were super costly to animate due to
how complex the process is so the fewer
humans they could tell the story with
the better that's also why if you look
closely you'll notice all of Andy's
friends at his party and all the people
at Pizza Planet look very similar to
Andy and his mom and sister they're the
same models with different hair and
clothes and a different color palette or
maybe this is the greatest family
reunion ever and those were our 10 fun
facts about Toy Story and also as a
bonus I would love to talk about how
amazingly bad Mr Potato Head is a
battleship the fact that he has hit
every point on the map except where Ham
ships are and that he's grouped all the
ships in the same place cracks me up had
to give it some love what are some of
your other favorite factoids from Toy
Story and check your sources folks don't
be spreading false information also
Disney Pixar or Disney Pixar movies
would you want to hear 10 fun facts
about let us know in the comments until
then you can follow me on Twitter at
it'sanavanston and follow And subscribe
to new rockstars add new rockstars for
more breakdowns of everything you love
remember you're my favorite deputy
You Got a Friend in Me
[Music]